i was basically ranting how uh i don't
watch anime nowadays because i mean you
guys know that anyway yeah but that's
not a revelation but i think a lot of
people think it just because like i've
fallen out of it it's not that it's that
like i find so much anime just so
goddamn boring now i just find it's not
even about it being boring it's just
redundant
like i just feel like it really says a
lot about society it's oh my god see he
laughed see you like the meme
okay why does it say a lot about society
jerry i want to hear your inspiration
it's just
he was gonna say he was gonna say he
says a lot about anime yeah
i was gonna say it really says a lot
about anime
but then the moment i said it really
says a lot it just like it was like
it was like
that was like the 100 unintentional pun
i support this okay it really says a lot
about anime when i
when i
when all it takes is for me to read a
synopsis yeah and i could probably tell
you with 90 accuracy what the first
three episodes of that anime is going to
be about yeah yeah and you know and not
even in like a like an arty farty
general type of way like in in a
detailed way yeah i would like to
preface is we have to preface every
argument you know there is always like
one or two shows that are good
entertainment no all anime sucks like
there's just
so much like mediocre stuff that is so
un uninspired and just rehashing of what
we've seen before and just just kind of
jumping off successful characters and
premises we've had before like i've seen
a joe earlier i was like there's so many
characters now i feel like i've watched
so many anime like i get the power
fantasy ones right yeah
but like
i understand that the point is is that
they're meant to be all powerful and
they can't [ __ ] up yeah
but like is that always that fun like is
that is that always like great like
sometimes i'm like can you have like a
floor or something like something that
makes you a little human so that i'm not
like bored out of my mind watching you
no because saitama's bold right that's a
flower
that's like the honestly i can relate
man
like you know like no i get it because
it's like
the but that's the problem right is that
i think the reason why power fantasies
are just they make the most like
quote-unquote perfect main characters is
because it if they had flaws it would
completely go against the point of being
a power fantasy it's like why would i
want to
self-insert myself into this
all-powerful character if this
this character that is supposed to be
the better version of me also makes
mistakes right i get that but at the
same time it's like okay that's fine if
you're self-inserting but not every
person who watches shows like that
wants to self-insert they just want to
watch a character that is completely
independent from them go through this
adventure or whatever right but
i don't know it's i mean i mean i i feel
like i i'm like the spokesperson for
like that that kind of anime yeah and
i'm just like yeah i completely
recognized that
it's it's the the problem with anime
nowadays is that one there is so much of
it
and number two a lot of it is what i
just call call disposable shows where
it's just not even like a show anymore
it's just content it's just something
you consume right so that's what that's
how i view a lot of visa guys right the
reason i watch a lot of visa guys
because it's exactly the same thing not
i'm not going to remember most of them
but i get the same kind of experience
it's it's the it's why i like it's why
it's the same region as what i see
people watching you know quote-unquote
trash tv shows for like trash reality
shows like you know you know what you're
getting with say you know you know
kitchen nightmares or hell's kitchen or
you know something along those lines
where it's just a repeatable format you
know gordon ramsay comes to a restaurant
and surprise surprise the restaurant
sucks you know
but that's why i also don't watch shows
like that either the exact same but
there's like a massive market yeah
absolutely i agree in some senses but
then it also feels like
like especially sky is just like so
inbred you know what i mean like it's
like they don't they don't take from
anything else yeah they just keep
[ __ ]
they just keep having internships
but like these shows when i'm watching
them it just feels like the shows aren't
trying to take from anything interesting
they're all just taking from the
successful show in their own category
yeah right so i kind of feel like i'm
just losing my mind watching these shows
where like no one even tries to do
anything even remotely different it's
it's the issue of like anime that is
inspired by anime like isaika is a genre
it's basically just like a self-sucking
like circle where it's it's it's it's
like the
is it uroboros where it's like [ __ ]
snake eating itself yeah yeah yeah
it is it isn't a robber and that's why
again like it it just feels derivative
like you you watch a show that is
supposedly brand new yeah and i just
read through the synopsis and i go i
feel like i've seen this show
i'm glad you say that sorry yeah just
because i feel like if i was just saying
that i feel like some people might argue
there's a language difference going on
where i can't fully understand the
nuance of these characters like i just
got like every time i go to a bookstore
right and i'm trying to find something
new and i go over to the light novel
section because i always want to see
like what's you know what's possible
what's poppin right yeah because i'm
just curious it's like okay maybe
there's like a change or something right
i go over and i see all these new titles
i've never heard of and i just look at
the title and i look at the covers and i
go how is this title and cover
any different to the one next to it yeah
like it doesn't it just they just look
like spin-offs of each other yeah just
from the feel and even going through the
synopsis i just think to myself
it's like this
book right here was inspired by the book
sitting next to it and vice versa
there's no difference it's just a reskin
of the same thing so every time you know
i do like the the what will i be
watching which is where i you know i go
to the next season biggest lie of the
century exactly
but
nowadays the reason why i still continue
that show
on my channel is because it's not
because i actually sit through and watch
all the anime i talk about it's so that
i can hopefully find that one show yeah
that would actually be non-derivative
and somewhat interesting for me to
actually go and watch which which is why
for like the isekai genre now especially
like the show that i'm like been picking
up so much is mushoka tensei yeah which
is just like it's it's it's the isekai
that basically started the whole isekai
light novel trend in terms of this is
the one this is the one series that from
what i can see has like this is the one
progenitor for all the tropes or a lot
of the tropes that you've seen and like
watching the anime adaptation which is
airing right now it's just a really
[ __ ] good show it's like not it's i
i'm not saying it's a good show for an
easter guy it's just a really good show
it's it's a great [ __ ] fact so and
it's like and it's not until so i've
started watching michoacan so i'm like
halfway through the first season because
it's season two right now right yeah
yeah yeah so i started watching the
first season just because gone and a
bunch of other people were like oh this
is the one that started all and i was
like bet i'll check it out yeah and yeah
i i completely agree like it's it's not
only you can see where all of the
origins of what made the isekai genre so
great came from but it's also yeah as
you said it's just a good show yeah like
like the fact that it just like with so
many sega and so many of these
disposable anime nowadays it's like the
the first episode airs and the anime is
like you know how it is you know how it
is yeah we don't need to explain [ __ ] we
don't need to like build up the world or
the characters you know this character
archetype you know this world and like i
watched i remember watching the first
episode of mushoka tensei and they spent
like a whole episode with where they're
building up this character and how he
dies and how he's a baby and how he like
wakes up in this world and he's just
like figuring out the world even though
in every other isa guy they're just like
dies easter guide it's like five minutes
yeah it really says it really says a lot
when i've watched some issac shut up
it really says a lot of people says a
lot about isakai society
when i start up a show
just a generic isakai show just wanting
to see what it is and
i think i'm watching episode one but it
feels like i'm halfway through the
season yeah just because they just
assume you already know all these tropes
yeah and it's like are we are you not
going to try and make it unique or
interesting or explain anything about
the world do you just assume that
everyone who watches the show already
has seen this show in some other form
cause like sometimes you also watch an
anime as well where you can tell that
the people behind us put like put a lot
of effort into this there's there's like
that extra that extra tinge that extra
sparkle that you know that you know when
an anime is just like clearly thrown
together like like like form of
michoacatense for example like you know
with a lot of anime that they speak
where the characters speak a different
language and they just don't even bother
and they just like they they translate
it back into japanese even though the
characters are not technically speaking
japanese yeah so in mashoku tensei they
didn't just make up one language they
made up two separate fantasy made up
languages for this show which is used in
the show and i've never seen that with
any other anime especially not any other
east card fancy anime yeah where the
characters are actually speaking to like
the fancy characters in their own
language which is just a made-up isakai
language or a made-up fantasy language
and then different species of different
languages so they they literally have
just made up two separate languages i'm
just like this is this is the [ __ ] that
not like everyone will appreciate but
this is this is one big indicator that
someone
the people producing this show really
gives a [ __ ] yeah you know it's like
welsh or something yeah
it's like icelandic they made this [ __ ]
up
because you watched villain saga right
yeah yeah so you remember that scene
where i i think i think it was like it
wasn't ask lad but it was thorafin
talking to some french people with also
english people there and european is
also is from uh scandinavian whatever
the scandinavian language is but they
were all speaking japanese
i really hate yeah and they were all
speaking japanese telling each other how
they can't understand what each other
was saying even though they were all
speaking japanese and i'm just like this
is villain saga [ __ ] amazing amazing
anime but little things like that are
just like immersion breaking you know it
really does make a difference and you
know i that's what i would argue some of
the greatest fantasy stories out there
is what made it so i mean like could you
imagine if you were watching [ __ ]
lord of the rings and yeah just elven
wasn't just spoken at all and like every
character speaking to the elvens in
english you know like that would be such
immersion breaking and it would also
just completely ruin the world building
even like netflix dramas right they'll
sometimes have like four or five
language different casts and everything
yeah yeah and that's like something that
i i always get like i appreciate a [ __ ]
ton yeah yeah yeah
that i love that like yeah but in in in
anime it just feels like that that never
ever happens
i know it's happened a few times i
remember which ones i know it has but it
just never really happens like yeah
it just sucks as well though that i feel
the main reason why a lot of anime just
opt to not do that is just because they
think oh the audience isn't going to be
[ __ ] right i mean i i think most in in
an ideal world they would like to do it
but it's just
there's so much anime being made now
there are so much of it is made under
like a big time crowd
you know i i wonder what the whole anime
thing is is it like a natural thing
if me as an anime fan who's watched
enemy for a very long time to get bored
of anime is it a natural occurrence or
is it or is it that i'm being picky i
don't know because
you know would you say you're you're
you're growing out of anime they're
definitely i don't think dare i say
really just a lot about society
it does say a lot about society one
thing that says a lot about society yeah
i feel like a lot of anime and you know
a lot of anime do this like this kind of
like disguise of like we're not for kids
but then you watch it and you watch the
character dialogue and how they talk and
you're like only a teenager would think
like this is how people talk to each
other yeah yeah like this is not this is
not like a real conversation that's why
like you know i hate to to use a western
example but like castlevania like the
script in castlevania was so goddamn
good yeah like the character
interactions in castlevania were so good
like i wanted to know more about these
characters every time they spoke even
the ones i didn't like i agree because
every single like every character when
they spoke about anything was a [ __ ]
delight but in anime it's always just
like it's got to serve the plot if it
doesn't turn about tits or
or funny i don't know like me being op
and like i was saying earlier as well
another thing i really dislike right
lelouch is like anime's favorite
character and it really [ __ ] shows
because like there's so many characters
that are like lelouch light but like
failed to see what what made lelouch so
good right it's like diet lelouch
lelouch
is good to me because what did make
lelouch good then one right first of all
you get you get lured in with this oh my
god he's a genius right he's cool he's
sick bro he's so strong and then you
realize he's a [ __ ] psychopath and
that he's he's scared as well like
anyone else in this world yeah and the
thing that i find that a lot of and you
know even like light right light in
death note light makes mistakes light
worries light panics light freaks out
right like it with a lot of these power
fantasy shows where they try and make a
character that like resembles or takes
from that i find that most of the time
it's so boring because there's
absolutely no other character trait to
them maybe the one thing they're sad
about is like the saitama thing where
like i'm so strong it's boring but even
then the way that one punch man does it
is really tasteful i don't know how they
i don't even know how to describe him
because the show doesn't take itself
saitama does it in a way that's kind of
like really fun and really playful that
doesn't really take itself too much but
anytime i watch these power fantasy
shows i feel like my brain is rotting
like i'm watching it and i'm just like
this is i'd rather watch big ed have
like some mental breakdown oh yeah
like i don't know how to put it like i
feel like anime treats me like i'm
stupid and i hate that yeah a lot of
anime shows do you the audience like
they're stupid yeah i hate it maybe
because i love them
jojo assumes i'm stupid and then doesn't
give a [ __ ] and carries on anyway yeah
jojo doesn't care
it's [ __ ] stupid but i love it
yeah i mean i was telling these boys
earlier that uh i've recently had to
start watching anime at like two times
speed at one point five times speed
which is like because like you're so
bored which is like [ __ ] insane to me
and i don't watch it at that point for
enjoyment it's just because someone
might consume yeah it's just for like
before like my seasonal videos where i
do have to watch everything i remember
it got to a point like two three years
ago where you look at the seasonal chart
and you're like if i watched everything
on this chart i'd literally be watching
two seasons worth of anime every week
yeah just to keep up with every show
being aired
i'm sorry
yeah and it's just like it's just
impossible to actually consume or watch
everything coming out now that's why a
lot of it is just it's just disposable
[ __ ] honestly and i'll go no i was about
saying and you know that's i guess like
one of the biggest like criticisms i get
about like joey doesn't watch anime it's
like
it's like yeah because i can't it's
there's so much [ __ ] out there so much
of it is so derivative that i would
deadass rather go back and watch shows
that i didn't get to watch all those
years ago or shows that came out before
i was even born right like i'd much
rather spend the time on that because
there is
there is in fact less of a selection
all those years ago than there is every
single year like new shows coming out
right yeah and it's like yeah like i
don't know like i'm limited with my time
right like i don't want to spend
[ __ ] you know 20 hours of the day
watching a bunch of [ __ ] that i'm not
gonna remember next week because it's so
[ __ ] mediocre and redundant you
always do like these all right so you do
the anime the seasonal anime videos yeah
right and like i i i watch
them watch them watch that watch
and like i feel like after i've watched
them now you'll always like talk about a
show or two that sounds amazing and i'll
never hear you ever mention ever again
what's up with that what's up with that
well uh i used to talk about shows that
have potential right okay and a few a
lot of them might not
why not say pan out and some of them do
they might fizzle out yeah they might
they might fizzle out that's why i do
like my end of year videos as well which
is just like okay these are the shows
that i actually stuck with because
they're okay so there are some good
shows that air every season but then
there are some shows that i feel are
just the best and can only are best
consumed via anime right there are some
shows that have interesting concepts
that i call like manga recommendation
shows uh which is which is i watched
like the first two episodes i'm like
this is really interesting but like you
know when it's just like an average
adaptation so what happens is i just go
off and read the manga and i'm like cool
i don't need to watch the anime anymore
i had a much better experience reading
them yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what
just happened yeah when you just watch
when you just watch the show you're just
like i can get this exact same
experience just reading manga and then
you do and then you're like great the
seasonal anime did its job as a manga
recommendation channel
there's like something about
reading manga
that
is way more palatable for shitty shows
yeah i don't know why but there's i
think when these characters are so
boring because i can just speed run
through that boring ass dialogue it's
way more enjoyable like well i think
it's because there are more
like places or more factors in anime
that leave for a larger room for arrow
yeah like because the only thing you
have to really worry about with a manga
is the dialogue and the artwork in the
story but whereas with anime you have
things like voice acting to worry about
you have things like sequencing to worry
about you have things like anime uh you
know animation and uh [ __ ] music and
like there's all these other factors
that could make that show look and feel
way more mediocre than the core of the
show yeah which is why like i rarely
read manga that hasn't been released yet
because i i like i do feel even now that
i'm reading more manga that if there's a
good anime adaptation it's just like
it's just untouched like like a good
anime adaptation of a good manga [ __ ]
untouched like i would rather go i'd
rather experience the anime firsthand
which is why when when these anime do
get released and i see one or two
episodes that's all i need to see to be
like okay this is going to be a mediocre
adaptation i'm just going to read the
manga you know and there's and there's
so many there's so many shows right now
which i feel like you can just read the
manga and you'll be completely fine with
it but there are just like those one or
two gems every season or like most
seasons where you're just like okay this
th this is a banger i'm glad anime
exists because of these [ __ ] shots
yeah yeah true like attack on titan's
one of those right oh yeah 100 i love it
i cannot read the manga for a tag one
time yeah yeah i refuse to read it yeah
yeah
but people can try and spoil it yeah i
mean
no i mean like i know you know not to
marry anyone who does read the manga but
i just feel like attack on titan anime
is the best way to like experience that
story i agree i can't imagine getting
like the emotional highs i did with the
story without having watched it in the
anime first yeah
and again it's because i feel that
because the added factors that make an
anime different from a manga like the
animation the voice acting the music
yeah in the case with the attack on
titan all of those were [ __ ] amazing
so it's just heightened it's about the
animators
but it just but that's the thing it's
like those like anime only factors only
heightened an already great story
characters so that's why i feel you just
get a better experience with the anime
yeah but a lot of anime adaptations
can't do that in fact they pull it down
sometimes yeah exactly which is why like
i there's some shows where like i know
he's gonna like slap like chainsaw man
yeah i'm like that's one show where i'm
like i could read the monk because i
know it's a [ __ ] amazing manga yeah
but i wanna i i wanna wait i wanna wait
for the anime see but that's good though
that you guys are waiting because in
case it sucks you have a great market to
look forward to
so it's just the win for you guys right
for me it's like i've already read the
manga multiple times now so like
i'm scared that my experience could go
really far down or it could just keep
getting better like i'm at a gambling
stage right now for you guys it's like i
don't care what the party is i'm [ __ ]
taking out the money